ladies and gentlemen of NASA this is  Charles Xavier help is on the way  you're doing space missions now cool we  get the astronauts we bring them home go  heat signatures rising fast we gotta get  out of here where's Jean where is she  she should be done did you hear what the  kids are calling you  Phoenix  hello Jean  are you the better question is who are  you  something's happening to me you would  have this control bad things happen but  it feels good that power destroyed  everything that ever came into contact  with until you  the Paxman fear you and what they fear  we seek to destroy shockula's ooh  go die  she stood off that she's not Jean  anymore  threatening me that's right  [Music]